I Wanna Be where the people are
poor child
the sea witch what has your father told
you about me
you like to stir up trouble
I'm only here to help
I'll make you human for three days is
that even possible that's what I do
I don't know well
I mean I just gave you the premium
package kid
come on girl inside the sink or swim
don't worry boys
and a chance look out Disney's The
Little Mermaid ready PG
in theaters May 26 tickets on sale now
we aren't supposed to be this far from
the palace Ariel getting old fence look
at this
you okay flounder sure you gotta show
them who's in charge
it's just cuddle
I wanna be
I wanna see you wanna see them dancing
you can't live in that world and that's
you've become a human yourself I don't
know life's full of tough choices amen
oh
look out
Disney's The Little Mermaid rated PGA in
theaters May 26 tickets on sale now
wish I could
[Music]
oh
ah